leading off our coronavirus coverage
tonight here at 11
frontline workers and seniors over 70
are continuing to get the copin 19
vaccine here in nevada
and tonight there's a call for more
vaccine volunteers
arko mana explains it's all hands on
deck
dr christina madison is part of nevada's
enormous effort to administer the kovit
19 vaccine
she's with roseman university a point of
dispensary helping with their
vaccination clinics
and she's doing this all as a volunteer
this is basically my super bowl
so there was no way that i wasn't going
to step up and be there to
to be part of this under directive 11
more medical professionals can apply to
become volunteers the list includes
nurses
pharmacists dentists and even
veterinarians they can apply on the
serve envy website
and choose between groups such as the
battleborn medical corps
and the medical reserve corps if they
have time
we want them the southern nevada health
district is looking for people dedicated
to the cause to join the local
volunteers they already have
this call to action as the work begins
at the catchment center and the encore
really what we're targeting now with
mass vaccination
sites opening up is is people that
actually can put
vaccine into people's arms we'll
recruit volunteers from different
sources
to support the immediate needs of some
of these venue events
more help will be required as the
vaccine rollout continues and dr
madison is ready we are we are in it for
the long haul
orco mana 8 news now the southern nevada
health district says there's also
volunteer opportunities for non-medical
personnel to help with
logistical needs we have more
information on how to get involved on
our website for you at eight newsnow dot
com